REMEMBER WE'RE NOT HERE TO JUDGE
ANYBODY.
WE WANT TO HANDLE
THIS WITH LOVE, RIGHT ?
YOU WANT TO TELL HIM HOW HIS
DRUG ABUSE HAS HURT YOU,
AND HE HURT HIMSELF, OKAY ?
HAROLD, WHAT TIME DID YOU
TELL HIM TO BE HERE ?
5:00, BUT HE'S
ALWAYS LATE.
NO, HE'LL BE HERE...
IN THREE, TWO, ONE...
IS THIS THE 5:00
FREE CRACK GIVEAWAY ?
♪ HE'S BEEN AWAY FOR A WHILE
BUT HE'S BACK AROUND ♪
Y'ALL TELL ANYBODY,
I'LL KILL YA !
♪ THE KOOKIEST CRACKHEAD
IN THE TOWN ♪
PEANUT BUTTER
AND CRACK SANDWICH.
♪ HE KICKED HIS HABIT
BACK IN THE JOINT ♪
♪ NOW HE'S BACK ON POINT ♪
LOOK OUT, CRACK,
HERE I COME !
( crashing )
♪ HE'S FINALLY HOME
HE'S TYRONE ♪♪
( narrator )
THIS WEEK, TYRONE GETS INVITED
TO AN INTERVENTION.
OH, YA-- LOCK
THE DOOR, GOOD IDEA.
HEY.
OKAY, TYRONE, DO YOU KNOW
WHY YOU'RE HERE ?
MM-HMM, I'M HERE FOR
SAME REASONS YOU IS, MAN,
I WANT SOME CRACK.
CRACK.
OKAY, TYRONE, WE ARE NOT
GIVING CRACK AWAY TODAY.
UH-HUH... WHA...
NO, NO.
WHAT TIME IS IT ?
IT'S 5:00.
DID I MISS THE 5:00
FREE CRACK GIVEAWAY ?
TYRONE, TYRONE, THESE ARE
YOUR FRIENDS HERE,
AND THEY HAVE SOMETHING
THEY'D LIKE TO SAY TO YOU.
I'VE BEEN TRICKED !
OKAY, TYRONE,
I'M WHAT IS KNOWN AS
AN INTERVENTION COUNSELOR.
OH !
YEAH, AND THESE PEOPLE
WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT YOUR DRUG USE.
WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT, MAN ?
I DON'T DO DRUGS.
WHAT Y'ALL TELL
HIM, HUH ?
COME ON,
BENEDICT ARNOLDS !
WHAT Y'ALL TELL HIM ?
RHONDA, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GO FIRST ?
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
WHAT IS GOING ON
IN HERE ?
DO WE GET
CRACK AT THE END ?
TYRONE, YOU KNOW
I LOVE YOU,
BUT I FEEL LIKE
DRUGS IS HURTING YOU
AND THEY'RE HURTING ME.
TYRONE, I WAS VERY HURT THAT
YOU CARJACKED ME THAT TIME.
WHAT YOU TALKING
ABOUT, RHONDA ?
I WOULD NEVER
CARJACK THAT UGLY-ASS CAR.
GET OUT THE CAR !
TYRONE, WHAT
ARE YOU DOING ?
WHO'S TYRONE, HUH ?
I DON'T KNOW
TYRONE !
NO, IT'S YOU WITH YOUR
CRUSTY-ASS LIPS !
STOP PLAYIN', RHONDA,
GET OUT THE CAR !
I DON'T
KNOW ANY TYRONE !
LOOK, THE POLICE FOUND
YOU THREE HOURS LATER
IN MY CAR, ASLEEP,
HIGH ON CRACK.
THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE,
RHONDA.
HOW CAN YOU SLEEP
IF YOU'RE HIGH ON CRACK, HMM ?
IT'S A CHINESE RIDDLE
FOR YOU.
OKAY, LET'S HAVE, UH,
JENNY AND ROB.
I AIN'T DO
THAT, RHONDA.
TYRONE, WE OPENED
OUR HOME TO YOU.
YOU LET YOUR ADDICTION
LEAD YOU TO ABUSE
OUR TRUST.
OH, JENNY, R-ROB,
LOOK, Y'ALL,
IT'S ME YOU'RE TALKING TO,
I-- I WOULD
NEVER HURT YOU.
OH, DON'T PLAY DUMB
WITH US, TYRONE.
I REMEMBER
THE WHOLE SPEECH.
I JUST NEED $200, I TAKE
THESE REAL ESTATE CLASSES,
AND I'M BACK ON
MY FEET, BABY.
I'M SERIOUS, ROB,
IT'S ME, BABY,
IT'S TYRONE.
I'M CLEANING UP MY ACT.
OKAY.
TYRONE !
ROB, JENNY, Y'ALL AIN'T GONNA
BE SORRY ABOUT THIS.
OH !
( Tyrone )
I STUDIED MY ASS OFF
FOR THAT REAL ESTATE TEST.
AGH !
WE'RE OFF
TO MY MOTHER'S.
WE'LL BE BACK
SUNDAY EVENING.
THE NUMBER'S ON THE FRIDGE
IF YOU NEED ANYTHING.
OKAY, BYE, JENNY,
BYE, ROB.
I PASSED MY TEST AND WAS
A CERTIFIED REAL ESTATE AGENT.
GOOD FOR YOU,
TYRONE.
YEAH, DAMN RIGHT,
GOOD FOR HIM.
( Rob )
HE SOLD OUR HOUSE
AND KEPT THE MONEY.
$450,000 !
WHERE'S THE MONEY,
TYRONE ?
HE SPENT IT ON A PARTY.
TOOK OUT AN AD
FOR IT IN THE PAPER.
YOU DIDN'T GET YOUR
INVITATION FOR THAT PARTY ?
OH, ROB, YOU SHOULD
HAVE SEEN IT,
WE HAD A PILE
OF CRACK THIS HIGH.
I HAD A HEART ATTACK.
HEART ATTACK, YEAH.
I'LL GIVE YOU
A HEART ATTACK !
ROB, ROB, ROB !
COME ON,
COME ON...
I'M GETTING A RESTRAINING
ORDER AGAINST YOU, ROB.
HAROLD, WHY DON'T
YOU GO NEXT ?
ALL RIGHT.
TYRONE, I'M HERE
BECAUSE I LOVE YOU.
WELL, IF YOU LOVE ME
SO MUCH, HAROLD,
WHY'D YOU GET ME FIRED
FROM THE POST OFFICE, HUH ?
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE ON YOUR ROUTE
COMPLAINED
OF RECEIVING OPEN MAIL ?
SEVEN ?
136, TYRONE.
AND THEN THERE WAS
THE INCIDENT WITH THE POWDER.
( sniffing )
OH !
ATTENTION, EVERYBODY,
BE ON THE LOOKOUT
FOR ANY ENVELOPES MARKED
"SENATOR TOM DASCHLE"
OR "TOM BROKAW".
IT MIGHT CONTAIN ANTHRAX.
FOR YOUR INFORMATION,
THAT'S A LITTLE WHITE POWDER.
HAROLD,
IS ANTHRAX BAD ?
YES, TYRONE.
AND IF IT FELL INTO
THE WRONG HANDS
IT COULD BE BIG TROUBLE.
I GOT THAT ANTHRAX
AND IT'S THE BOMB, BABY.
60 BUCKS !
IF THAT MAN HADN'T
TURNED YOU IN,
IT WOULD'VE
BEEN A DISASTER.
Y'ALL ACT LIKE CRACK
IS SO BAD !
WELL, LIKE
THE GOOD BOOK SAYS:
LET HE WHO IS WITHOUT SIN,
THROWETH THE FIRST ROCK
AND I SHALT SMOKETH IT.
BASICALLY, TYRONE,
WE WOULD LIKE YOU TO CHECK
INTO REHABILITATION IMMEDIATELY.
AW !
ALL RIGHT, OKAY,
FINE, FINE.
YOU KNOW WHAT ?
I NEED TO GET BETTER,
Y'ALL ARE RIGHT.
BUT FIRST STEP IS FIRST,
I NEED TO GO TO THE BATHROOM,
AND THEN I'M ON MY WAY
TO RECOVERY, RHONDA.
I GOT THE KEY.
AND THAT WASN'T ME,
RHONDA !
GO TO THE BATHROOM !
OKAY, THANK-- I'VE GOT
IT FROM HERE, THANK YOU.
I'LL BE RIGHT OUT.
OH !
OH, WHY DIDN'T THEY SAY THERE
AIN'T NO WINDOWS IN HERE ?
OH !
HERE GOES NOTHIN' !
( flushing )
DRUGS HAVE
RUINED MY LIFE !
♪ HE'S FINALLY HOME
HE'S TYRONE ♪♪